hey that's new dr. Wallach how are you
fine thank you how can we help you okay
first of all we shall wait for allows
you to take the call being a patient
professional advocate back in December
12 of 17 I have a patient in the
hospital she was diagnosed with
pneumonia our diabetes etc so I talked
to you in reference to what can we do
about the pneumonia other than the
antibiotic that she was receiving in the
hospital no I was instructed to give her
colloidal silver
nebulizer which I proceeded to do that I
gave her like 30 ppm and just asked her
to just inhale the facemask more about
two to three minutes each day and come
to find out within two days she was free
of pneumonia so I just want to get that
testimony testimony how great a lot of
silver can be for all human beings
doctors will not share this with the
patient know again when I was a
colloidal silver was one of the original
antibiotics it goes back hundreds of
years they were using solutions of
silver as a disinfectant for infected
wounds and things like that so this is
not new but it is one of those things
this perennial it'll last forever
because the principles are correct
absolutely so moving forward I have a
patient she's 60 years of age female
fine 214 pounds
she was diagnosed with vascular dementia
hypertension and low sodium however she
has the history of hydrochloric I died
so the patient ended up in the emergency
room about three days ago hyponatremia
low sodium and of course with the
seizure so my question to you first of
all she also she refused to take any
more conventional drugs due to the major
major side effects
hydrochloride what is the course of
action or my patient now is she at home
or so in the hospital okay okay we've
only got a moment here drew so char what
would you do for a lady who's 114 pounds
has high blood pressure and she's got
vascular dementia she's got something
might look clinically like Alzheimer
disease buzzer cause she's got plaque in
the arteries in her brain doesn't have
enough oxygen getting to the brain what
would you do to help get more oxygen to
her brain and support healthy blood
pressure and help this lady for those
issues that would get her on a healthy
brain and heart pack and I would get
around the ultimate daily classic and
the vitamin b3 perfect